welcome to the 1880s
this train has been running through
these passes for over a century
there's no cell service up here no gas
stations and a whole lot of mountains
it's also the highest the longest and
one of the last authentic steam
railroads left in the country
there's probably no better ride with the
steam engine than this ride right here
that's jeff stebbins jeff is an engineer
for this train officially known as the
cumbers and toltec railway
he's been working on this railroad for
the last 19 years on this 64 miles of
railroad i have about 50 000 miles that
would translate out to around the earth
about two times
today's trains are powered by diesel and
electricity but this one keeps it old
school by running on coal
we shovel about three and a half to four
and a half tons of coal a day
it's dirty work and back in the 1930s
trains began changing to diesel because
it was cheaper and more efficient
the coal powered engines were phased out
this one survived thanks to the people
who cared about it and saw its beauty
this 64 miles of railroading through
southern colorado northern new mexico it
doesn't get much more beautiful than
this
the other thing about coal is that it
produces all that iconic smoke coming
off the train
the train takes visitors along its route
in the summer and fall
people come for the history more than
for the thrill of it
the train's top speed is only 20 miles
an hour
i love working on the railroad and i
look forward to
each morning that i come here there's
really
no place i'd rather be than the filthy
dirty locomotive
you